>>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
BREAKING NEWS IN THE POLITICS
LEAD.
MOMENTS AGO, BRAND-NEW SUBPOENAS
WERE ISSUED FOR FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE.
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE DEADLY JANUARY
6th INSURRECTION IS SHIFTING
INTO HIGH GEAR, PREPARING TO DO
BATTLE WITH SOME PRETTY BIG
NAMES IN THE TRUMP WORLD.
THE PANEL SAYS FUELED THE BIG
LIE AND PERHAPS INCITED THE
VIOLENT INSURRECTION.
STEPHEN MILLER, KAYLEIGH McENANY
AND FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESIDENTIAL PERSONNEL OFFICE
DIRECTOR JOHN McENTEE ARE THREE
OF THE NEW NAMES ADDED TO THE
LONG LIST OF TRUMP ALLIES THE
PANEL WANTS TO HEAR FROM.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO BRIAN NOBLES
LIVE FROM CAPITOL HILL.
THESE ARE SOME REALLY CLOSE
ALLIES OF TRUMP'S.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT, JAKE.
THIS IS A GROUP WITH VERY CLOSE
TYCE TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
TEN SUBPOENAS IN ALL ISSUED
TODAY BY THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE.
BUT WHAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN IS
WHETHER OR NOT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE THE POWER TO FORCE
THIS GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR REQUEST.
NEW TARGETS TO HELP UNCOVER WHO
WAS BEHIND THE INSURRECTION,
NARROWING IN ON THOSE CLOSEST TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD
TRUMP.
THE COMMITTEE DROPPING MORE
SUBPOENAS TODAY.
TEN NEW ONES, INCLUDING KEY
PLAYERS IN THE TRUMP ORBIT AND
THE TIME BETWEEN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION AND JANUARY 6th.
THE BIGGEST NAMES, LONGTIME
LOYAL ADVISER STEPHEN MILLER,
BODY MAN TURNED WHITE HOUSE
PERSONNEL CHIEF JOHNNY McENTEE
AND FORMER PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
McENANY, ONE OF THE LOUDEST
VOICES IN TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE
PEDDLING THE BIG LIE ABOUT THE
ELECTION RESULTS BOTH IN AND
OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION
MATTERS.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES MATTERS.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS DEMOCRAT OFFICIALS
SYSTEMATICALLY TRYING TO DO AN
END RUN AROUND THE CONSTITUTION
TO TIP THE SCALES OF THE
ELECTION IN THEIR FAVOR.
>> Reporter: THE COMMITTEE'S
REQUEST TUESDAY COME ONE DAY
AFTER THEY ISSUED A BATCH OF
SUBPOENAS TO OTHER HIGH-RANKING
TRUMP OFFICIALS LIKE BILL
STEPIEN AND JASON MILLER.
THE COMMITTEE ALSO WANTS TO HEAR
FROM JOHN EASTMAN.
THE CONSERVATIVE LAWYER WHO
AUTHORED THE MEMO OUTLINING
FRINGE LEGAL THEORYS ABOUT
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE'S AUTHORITY TO OVERTURN
ELECTION RESULTS AS PART OF A
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN.
>> WE KNOW THERE WAS FRAUD,
TRADITIONAL FRAUD THAT OCCURRED.
WE KNOW THAT DEAD PEOPLE VOTED.
>> Reporter: AND FORMER NEW YORK
CITY POLICE COMMISSIONER BERNARD
KERIK, ALL FOUR OF THEM,
STEPIEN, MILLER, EASTMAN AND
KERIK AMONG THOSE GATHERED AT A
D.C. HOTEL FOR WHAT IS DESCRIBED
AS A WAR ROOM TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
KERIK ALREADY WARNING THAT HE
DOES NOT PLAN TO COMPLY.
I WILL NOT BE THREATENED,
INTIMIDATED, FORCED INTO
BANKRUPTCY OR SILENCED AT THE
HANDS OF THIS COMMITTEE WHO ARE
NOT LOOKING FOR TRUTH BUT
TARGETING PATRIOTS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM
THAT WANTED NOTHING MORE TO
INVESTIGATE AND EXPOSE THOSE
IRREGULARITIES.
KERIK SAID IN A STATEMENT.
HIS CONFRONTATIONAL TONE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE DIFFICULT TIME
THE COMMITTEE IS HAVING GETTING
TRUMP ALLIES TO COOPERATE.
THEIR ABILITY TO GET WITNESSES
TO COOPERATE HINGING IN PART ON
A DECISION BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHICH HAS YET TO WEIGH
IN ON A CRIMICAL CONTEMPT
REFERRAL OF STEVE BANNON WHO HAS
OPENLY DEFIED A SUBPOENA.
MERRICK GARLAND REFUSING TO SHED
ANY LIGHT ON HOW THE DOJ PLANS
TO RESPOND.
>> WE EVALUATE THESE IN THE
NORMAL WAY WE DO.
FACTS AND THE LAW.
AND APPLYING THE PRINCIPLES OF
PROSECUTION.
>> Reporter: JUST A LITTLE MORE
ON THE OTHER SUBPOENA TARGETS
THAT MAY NOT BE AS PUBLIC NAMES
AS SOME OF THE NAMES JUST
MENTIONED.
NICHOLAS LUNA, SOMEONE WHO
SERVED AS THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
BODY MAN.
BEN WILLIAMSON, CLOSE WITH THE
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF.
MARK MEADOWS.
AND KEITH KELLOGG.
THIS NAME IS INTERESTING.
THE FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER TO THE VICE PRESIDENT,
MIKE PENCE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
SPECIFIC TIES TO THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
ISSUED A SUBPOENA FOR.
JAKE?
>> RYAN NOBLES ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH THE BREAKING NEWS.
THANKS.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH
GLORIA BORGER AND KIM.
IT'S BEEN ABOUT TWO WEEKS SINCE
A MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, A BIPARTISAN
VOTE, VOTED TO REFER CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS CHARGES
AGAINST BANNON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
HAS NOT YET WEIGHED IN.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING
TO TAKE BEFORE HE MAKES A
DECISION ONE WAY OR THE OTHER?
>> GLORIA AND I WERE TALKING OFF
AIR.
THERE'S A NEW U.S. ATTORNEY AND
THAT'S THE PERSON THAT WOULD
MAKE THIS DECISION.
AND SO IT COULD BE A MATTER OF
DAYS.
COULD BE A MATTER OF WEEKS BUT
THIS HAS TO HAPPEN REALLY SOON
OR WE ARE GOING TO SEE A BREAK
DOWN OF CONGRESS ITSELF.
AND ITS ABILITY TO DO THESE
KINDS OF INVESTIGATIONS WHICH
FRANKLY THE PROBLEM TRACES BACK
TO THE FIRST IMPEACHMENT AND
ACQUITTAL ON OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS.
CONGRESS SAID IT'S OKAY IF YOU
IGNORE ALL REQUESTS, WHITE
HOUSE, AND HERE WE'RE PAYING THE
PRICE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE PAYING
THE PRICE.
>> THAT'S THE POINT.
UNTIL THEY MAKE A DECISION,
RIGHT, UNTIL THESE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS, STEPHEN MILLER,
McENANY AND OTHERS, UNTIL THEY
SEE WHETHER OR NOT BANNON IS
FORCED TO COMPLY, THEY'LL JUST
FOLLOW HIS LEAD, I WOULD THINK.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF SOME OF
THESE SUBPOENAS AGAINST McENANY,
McENTEE AND OTHERS?
>> THESE WERE PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO HAD DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PRRKTS
SAT IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
OVERHEARD THE PRESIDENT, WERE IN
THE ROOM WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
THEY KIND OF OUTLINE IT HERE.
MADE PUBLIC STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED RIGGED ELECTION, THE
BIG LIE.
THEY TELL YOU.
THEY GIVE YOU THE ROAD MAP ABOUT
WHY THEY ARE -- THEY NEED TO
HEAR FROM THEM BECAUSE THEY KNOW
WHAT WENT ON IN THE ROOM WHEN
THEY WERE THERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND SO THEY'VE ALREADY
INTERVIEWED OTHER PEOPLE,
CLEARLY, WHO ARE TELLING THEM A
STORY AND NOW THEY'RE GOING TO
THEM AND SAYING, OKAY, WE KNOW
THIS HAPPENED.
TELL ME ABOUT IT.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO THEY COULD CLAIM
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE THEY WORKED IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE BATCH WE HAD YESTERDAY, I
BELIEVE IT WAS YESTERDAY, DIDN'T
WORK IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
STEVE BANNON DID NOT WORK IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
YET HE IS CLAIMING PRIVILEGE.
THESE PEOPLE WILL CERTAINLY TRY
AND CLAIM THAT WHICH IS WHY THEY
ARE SORT OF WAITING ON WHAT
MERRICK GARLAND DECIDES TO DO AT
DOJ.
.
>> IN THAT CLIP WE SAW KAYLEIGH
McENANY LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT A CRIME TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF IT WERE SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED ON THE FIRST DAY AS
PRESS SECRETARY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE COMMITTEE
IS LOOKING FOR HERE.
WHAT DO THEY WANT TO KNOW?
IT'S NOT JUST DID THE PRESIDENT
TELL YOU TO GO OUT THERE AND LIE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE,
OF COURSE HE DID.
>> WELL, THEY ARE LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT STEPS WERE TAKEN WITHIN
GOVERNMENT THAT LED TO THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
OF COURSE OVER 500 OF THE
INSURRECTIONISTS HAVE BEEN
PAYING THE PRICE ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, BUT
NO ONE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH WHO
FUNDED IT.
HOW WELL ORGANIZED WAS IT AND
WHO WAS IN ON IT.
THESE COULD LEAD TO CHARGES OF
CONSPIRACY, RICO CHARGES,
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS AND ALSO
QUESTIONS ON WHETHER DONALD
TRUMP INCITED AN INSURRECTION,
WHICH GETS TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
BUT I PUT A PIN IN THIS WHOLE
THING WITH THE CONTEMPT.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK.
ONE YEAR FROM TODAY, ONE YEAR
FROM TODAY IS THE DAY FOR
MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND IF THAT, AS THE TEA
LEAVES APPEAR TO BE READING,
GOES TO THE REPUBLICANS, THE
ENTIRE THING --
>> WILL BE SHUT DOWN.
>> AND THESE CLAIMS ARE BOGUS.
THESE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
CLAIMS.
BUT IT TAKES AWHILE TO GET THEM
THROUGH THE COURT.
>> ONE MORE THING ABOUT KAYLEIGH
McENANY.
THE COMMITTEE SAYS THAT MS.
McENANY WAS REPORTEDLY PRESENT
AT TIMES WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AS HE WATCHED THE
JANUARY 6th ATTACK.
WE'VE HEARD REPORTS HE WAS
PLEASED WITH IT.
THAT, LOOK AT ALL THESE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE FOR ME.
THEY BELIEVE THE ELECTION WAS
RIGGED.
WELL, KAYLEIGH McENANY, IF SHE
WERE TO TESTIFY AND NOT TRY TO
STONEWALL AND RUN OUT THE CLOCK,
IF SHE WERE TO TESTIFY,
TRUTHFULLY, SHE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SHED SOME LIGHT ON EXACTLY WHAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS SAYING DURING
THE ATTACK, WHAT HE WAS
THINKING.
MAYBE HE WAS SAYING, OH, LOOK AT
THIS.
THIS IS GREAT.
>> AND THIS BEARS ON CRIMINAL
INTENT.
>> IT DOES.
>> AND ISN'T THE IDEA HERE
WHETHER OR NOT, LOOK, WE DID A
WHOLE DOCUMENTARY ABOUT THIS.
THIS WAS A MONTHS-LONG CAMPAIGN
TO TRY TO SUBVERT DEMOCRACY.
IT DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN JANUARY
6th.
HE TRIED EVERY LEGAL MEAN AND
THEN TRIED EXTRA LEGAL MEANS AND
HERE WE HAVE A QUESTION, DID
DONALD TRUMP, STEVE BANNON AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY INTEND FOR
JANUARY 6th TO BE AN ATTEMPT TO
EITHER INTIMIDATE OR THREATEN OR
FORCE THE ELECTORS TO GO TO HIM
INSTEAD TOF JOE BIDEN?
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE
REPORTED IN THE DOCUMENTARY IS
THERE WERE MEMBERS OF THE BIDEN
TEAM FOR ABOUT AN HOUR THAT DAY,
JANUARY 6th, WHO THOUGHT THAT
TRUMP HAD SUCCEEDED.
WHO THOUGHT THAT THE ELECTORS
COUNTING HAD STOPPED AND DONALD
TRUMP HAD FIGURED OUT A WAY TO
CLING TO POWER.
>> LISTEN, THIS IS NOT SO MUCH
LOOKING IN THE PAST.
IT'S LOOKING IN THE FUTURE.
THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO
PROBABLY HAPPEN TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IF THIS CONTINUES.
THAT IS, IF THIS REPUBLICAN --
NEW WAVE REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER OF
THE LAW OF THE RULE OF LAW, THE
NOTION OF GOVERNMENT BY WE THE
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE EASTMAN MEMO, IT'S A
STUNNING SORT OF OUTMANEUVERING
OF THE CONSTITUTION ITSELF.
>> COMPLETELY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE'LL SEE.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
THE IDEA IS, JUST TO BE CLEAR,
THIS ISN'T ABOUT WHO GETS TO
CAST VOTES.
THIS IS ABOUT WHOSE VOTES COUNT.
THAT WAS ABOUT STEALING VOTES
FROM THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
THE PEOPLE IN SEVEN STATES WHO
VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> AND THESE ARE PEOPLE, LIKE
KEITH KELLOGG, WHO WAS
APPARENTLY THERE WHEN DONALD
TRUMP WAS SAYING TO MIKE PENCE,
YOU GOT TO DECERTIFY THIS
ELECTION.
SO THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
EYEWITNESSES TO A PRESIDENT
TRYING